con el sistema sanitario a punto de
colapsar la región del amazonas ya
cuenta con casi seis mil fallecidos por
kobe 19 según las autoridades algunos
doctores de la zona están usando sus
propios vehículos para transportar a los
pacientes y hace unos días llegaron
nuevos suministros de oxígeno mientras
el personal sanitario continúa
alternando el oxígeno entre los enfermos
en algunos hospitales de la zona
los vecinos de manaos la capital del
estado se han puesto manos a la obra
para luchar contra el kobe 19 cargados
de desinfectantes la comunidad ha salido
a las calles de la localidad
todo el mundo está preocupado por esta
nueva variante según los científicos
mañana comienza una nueva ola de esta
enfermedad y le rezamos a dios para que
no vuelva a pasar más nosotros nos
estamos anticipando haciendo este
trabajo preventivo que es limpiar
nuestras calles
todo el mundo hace su parte por la
comunidad de ayuda al gobierno seguro
que este virus acabará pronto no solo en
el amazonas sino en todo brasil y
seguirnos aquí nomás nada más y todo
parece
brasil es el tercer país con más muertos
en el mundo y roza los 210.000 y es el
tercero en contagios por detrás de eeuu
e india